it may actually be an understatement to
call matt damon a prolific actor
he's in dozens of movies including
goodwill hunting saving private ryan and
the bourne franchise
he's long been considered one of the
most successful actors in hollywood
thanks to his impressive range likable
screen presence and other talents
don't forget that he wrote goodwill
hunting with ben affleck
how do you like them damon has endured
some rough patches of course but he
remains an integral part of the film
industry
back in 2007 damon was named hollywood's
most bankable star with the cbc
reporting
for every dollar he was paid for his
last three roles damon brought in 29 us
dollars of gross income
aside from his many great films daemon
has been part of several projects that
didn't quite live up to expectations
from flops like suburbicon to movies
that got mostly average reviews such as
titan ae
damon has seen every side of a movie's
possible critical reception
thankfully for him one of his less
popular movies a wartime action thriller
based on a non-fiction book is getting
another chance on netflix
and so far and staying high on the
streaming platform's trending list
the 2010 movie green zone was inspired
by the book
imperial life in the emerald city
written by journalist rajiv chandra
sacram
the book describes what it was like
within the green zone the international
zone of baghdad during the 2003 us
invasion of iraq and in the subsequent
transfer of power
green zone which reunites damon with
foreign supremacy and born ultimatum
director paul greengrass
follows us army chief warrant officer
roy miller played by damon
who realizes that the intelligence the
pentagon is receiving is faulty as all
of their leads for weapons of mass
destruction end up going nowhere
miller decides to take things into his
own hands and begins hunting for wmd on
his own while uncovering some harsh
troops along the way
green zone won over about half of
critics with a rating of 53
on rotten tomatoes but it was considered
a flop at the box office
some critics said that green zones
strayed a bit too far from the troop but
others appreciated its commentary on the
motivation behind the war in iraq
andrew o'hagan of the evening standard
went so far as to call it one of the
best war films ever made
he added it exposed the terrible lies
that stood behind the decision of the us
and britain to prosecute the war
and it does so in a way that is
dramatically brilliant morally complex
and relentlessly thrilling
the majority of recent viewers have
positive things to say about greenstone
with some taking to social media to
offer their compliments
one twitter user said they consider it
to be an underrated action movie and yet
another confessed that they enjoyed it
more than they expected to
others have commented on how green zone
shines a light on the conspiracy
surrounding the war on iraq
adding that damon's stellar performance
introduces another layer of excitement
we can sit around dig holes all day want
to get something done
audience critiques on rotten tomatoes
also mostly lean positive with almost
all an agreement that damon's acting is
a strong point of the film
one reviewer succinctly said i'm a fan
of matt damon he is perfectly
satisfactory in the role of roy miller
he holds things together
when asked about how accurate the film
actually is during a 2010
interview damon told collider that some
real-life people had to be boiled down
to one central character to make the
story work better
he said there were no weapons in iraq
that's true a lot of people went there
thinking there were
that's true too no one's really
explained what the happened
that's true too i mean what we have in
the movie is yeah we have a guy playing
kind of a neocon type who actually
invented a source right
so that's not based on anything that's
obviously something that for the movie
for the kind of architecture of a
thriller to work
it needs to boil down to a couple
characters fans of the bourne
franchise's action-packed plotlines will
likely enjoy seeing damon in another
thrilling role while history and
politics buffs will appreciate the
social commentary of green zone check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
movies on netflix are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you